here's an incredible thought
you are the living ancestor of an
unbroken chain of lives stretching from
you through your mother and your
grandmother all the way back through the
complete history of life on planet earth
to the very first life forms that
appeared around 4 billion years ago
isn't that mind-blowing
and the fact that you exist proves that
this is true
combined of course with our
understanding of evolutionary history
where life on earth has evolved into
more complex forms over time due to
different pressures from the environment
and competition with other animals
try and imagine all of your direct
ancestors all of those individual
creatures that managed to survive birth
avoided being eaten or dying from
disease and getting enough food for long
enough so that they could rear their
young over and over and over again until
it all ended up with you
every single life form in that chain
managed to do that
now i've oversimplified a little bit by
just talking about a chain of life in
reality there's a big web of lives going
back into the past but just to keep
things simple you can think about a
chain of all of your ancestral mums
imagine your mum and then her mum and
her mum and so on and so on going back
through all of human civilization back
to when we were human hunter-gatherers
in africa
direct ancestors of yours survived a
super volcano that dimmed the sun for
six whole years and glacial periods
where the earth turned cold and dry and
the total global population of humans is
estimated to have been about 10 000
people and may have been even lower
then back through the ages when our
ancestors were hunted by saber-toothed
cats in the savannas of africa and lived
in a world shared with giant gorilla
horses and giant sloths the size of
elephants
then through our common ancestors with
the great apes and the monkeys through
to the animals that survived the impact
of the meteorite that killed off most of
the dinosaurs
the last common ancestor of humans and
mice was a hundred million years ago and
all of the mammals including you came
from the first mammals which were small
shrew-like animals
then back through earlier animals to the
common ancestor with dinosaurs and
modern reptiles and birds
you're related to the first reptiles
which evolved from amphibians which
evolved from fish and they came from
even earlier vertebrates and these came
from the first animals to have a heart
and circulatory system and then worms
were the first bilateral symmetry to the
first animals with nerves and muscles to
sponge like creatures with the first
different kinds of tissues and before
multicellular organisms were just single
cells complex cells oxygen breathing
cells first cells like bacteria back to
the very first life forms that turned
from mixtures of chemicals to
self-replicating molecules
you come from an unbroken chain of lives
that span that unimaginable time you're
connected to eons and eons of creatures
all fighting for survival and winning
and i think that's so incredible it
completely blows my mind
so what can we conclude from this
amazing thought experiment
for me
the thing i take away is the fact that
this timeline of life doesn't just apply
to us humans it applies to all life on
earth right now the earth is kind of
like a living museum
capturing the results of all of this
evolutionary history so i think it's
really important we try and preserve as
much biodiversity as we can on earth
but that's about it for this video as
ever there's a poster available check in
the link in the description below